[Music]
come on i know right this is essentially
a previously on previously on segment
we're pretty tired of it too mr rinner
when does the madness end drawing a
dragon with boobs crossing your legs
like this shouldn't the karate
instructor tell maya that her fists are
too close to her body in this stance i
mean i know she could take me regardless
but that's bad form i was prepared to
send this show for taking this long for
echo to appear or maybe send media in
general for dragging their feet on
planning an amazing character like echo
and center stage but see the problem is
that i [ __ ] love watching this
diverse powerhouse of a woman burst onto
the scene and i can't help but give sins
back sorry to let you down sinners this
is a big moment for representation and
deserves recognition
i was about to clear your name from the
suit
until you decided to crash through the
skylight yeah but why not give her a
heads up on what your plans were when
you were last together instead of the
this is probably the last time we meet
here's my phone number for emergency
spiel from the previous episode you
could have given kate a little more
insight and then maybe she doesn't make
this mistake also what do you mean she
decided to crash through the skylight
kate is overconfident but i have a hard
time believing she'd opt for a
purposeful roof crash you good kate is
snarky and rebellious and overall a
delight to watch but does she fear any
consequences sure the mobsters are
humorous and may be dumb to the point of
being approachable but there are so many
instances of her not valuing her own
life which makes her yet another level
of unrelatable discount corey feldman
is it normally from high shelving units
directly into freestanding wooden
splinter shelves i've never tried but
seems like there were other directions
clint could have aimed this convenient
and well-placed trampoline followed by
this convenient and well-placed quiver
of arrows near this convenient bow
followed by a convenient pit of
convenient balls and i'm done i get he's
done with straight up killing people but
he could have shot maya in the shoulder
or leg he has no issues doing that to
her henchmen hawkeye shoots an arrow
while dramatically falling cliche also
diving into a children's stinky ball pit
without fear or reservation hawkeye is
shooting people in arms and shoulders
and hands and that's fine but wouldn't
the bad guys still be able to crawl to
their weapons i mean the show won't let
them so that clinton cate can escape but
in real life i'm pretty sure at least
one of the henchmen would still be a
threat if the goal is to kick kazi over
just boot him in the poop rather than
swinging around the thingy sure is cool
of everyone to suddenly be not so
injured all together at the same time
this driving sequence which we're
witnessing almost the entire time from
the car is brilliantly executed and yes
i'm well aware of the similar sequence
in the classic noir gun crazy but even
if this is an homage to that it's a
well-constructed one i love it how many
we got
but we suddenly do not have a part of
the car that was here a moment ago i'm
sure that car door piece has been
removed for the ensuing stun portion of
this amazing car scene but if it's
absence doesn't bother me throughout the
next few minutes this long shot is fun
to watch i'm in the car i'm riding
around i'm invested i'm wondering why
the car in front of you is running a red
light we're going to die
hit the wheels with the putty hero might
have been a good idea to let kate know
that this was the arrow she was using
and what to do with it before she fired
hawkeye really sucks at giving useful
information out at the time it's
actually needed there are four arrows
more dangerous than that one i'm sorry
you said i just murdered people wrong
trying to out lethal lethal weapon with
all this senseless christmas tree murder
here acid arrows drop the stop legs or
you know wait until the car catches up
with you and shoot them at the tires or
engine to stop them but sure stop lights
considering kate has no understanding of
each arrow's abilities i find it atchi
calmly aims for the dashboard of the car
without fear of the possibility that her
close proximity could place her in a
range of maiming death or dismemberment
i mean yay it's just a poof cloud and
everyone important survives episode four
but she shouldn't know that
and for some reason kate is an
immediately fired upon by all of the
people who wanted to kill them only
moments ago i can't tell which is more
unlikely that pizza dog hasn't shut all
over the apartment by now or that kate
and clint somehow know how to
synchronize their impossible leap turn
grab stunt with zero practice what is
maya shooting at kate and clint are
falling down not forward she should be
running to the side of the bridge naming
down see there were peas in the freezer
and kate didn't need to put a box of
pizza on her head last episode she had
more logical choices only seven seconds
pass from the time kate begins to write
this until she shows that it reads says
it's okay if you can't be home for
christmas and there's just no way she
wrote this legibly that fast how could
they not opt for trust a bro moving co
it rhymes i am disappointed but why are
they keeping the toys or better question
why were toys left behind when the store
boasted total stock liquidation
when i'm often asked if you could learn
any language instantly what language
would it be i always say mandarin seeing
this though i'm thinking that instantly
learning asl would be so [ __ ] cool
damn it marvel now i'm conflicted and
i'm blaming you this phone has a rokit
logo down here and i have a sinking
feeling that's an easter egg which
reminds me that i want to know but i
also don't want to do the work to figure
it out you know i really hate marvel for
doing their job so well i know this may
sound weird but
i've dreamed of this for as long as i
can remember telling someone you just
met a day ago that you've always dreamed
of being his partner no not weird at all
my dad was
fearless who would name their child
fearless i'm not a role model
disrespecting charles barkley's wishes
to not be a role model by making him
your role model for not wanting to be a
role model you uh you care to elaborate
not really and then five seconds later
hawkeye elaborates despite saying he
didn't care to stop sending mixed
messages just be an ass you try to step
your mom's fiancee in the face because
he has everything to gain from her mom's
death these two idiots continue to have
a conversation about all this inside a
taxi no way in hell she knew how to
spell qazzi's last name on the first try
nope
you shot me i'm sorry i'm sorry
fear does not exist in this dojo
i seem to have fallen down a cliff i'm
still alive but i'm very badly injured
going and going and going
okay come out and play
[Music]
very differently
get off my train
what do you think
i think it's like a wax magazine with a
pulse
throwing a couple of arms
oh
i think i need to start over thing
doesn't look natural